oh my god everybody this is the greatest
thing ever most unexpected thing to drop
Friday night so we got to talk about all
the crazy stuff that showed up in that
concept art like Thor's new weapon which
is either his axe or ultimate Thor's
hammer
in that very sanctuary looking set to
say says they were filming on during day
one so there's a new round of the
spider-man giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video that's for one of
those new Hasbro spider-man figures and
huge shout out to my friend Comics
Torian for answering all my questions
about hiring minions that's right you
might see some minions helping me edit
videos on emergency awesome soon so
let's do it the picture of the hardback
comic that you're seeing on the table
here is from Infinity Gauntlet but it's
basically like a giant collective
special edition of the Infinity Saga
which contains a bunch of different
infinity storylines Infinity Gauntlet is
just one of those and that's basically
what's going to be happening in the
first movie but obviously the MCU
changes things
so all these sticky notes are just like
the really important things that they
want to include in the movie so
obviously it's not all going to be in
there and I'll do a separate video that
explains the reading order in all the
different storylines that make up the
Sandoz infinity saga because you have
Infinity Gauntlet Infinity Gauntlet
aftermath infinity war which is actually
a different comic book even though
that's the name of the movie then after
that you have things like infinity
crusade infinity watch which are
completely different ideas so it goes on
and on there is a lot of Bannos Infinity
Gauntlet story lines you don't need to
read them all but if you do want to it's
actually really good I mean it's a
really cool storyline but the only one
you should check out is Infinity
Gauntlet
that's the storyline of him going around
collecting the gems the first time
you've probably seen that comic book
panel with him standing next to Mephisto
and Mephisto going oh my god he's
actually going to do it the bastard is
going to do it snaps his fingers in a
race is half of all life in the galaxy
that's the pitch for the first film
that's the thing that the Avengers Tony
Stark are trying to stop in the way they
explain this is that they're filming
both of these Avengers movies back to
back even though the second movie isn't
going to be called infinity war anymore
it'll be called infinity crusade or
something completely different but they
will be pull
from the comics so if you read the stuff
that comes after the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline there they'll be pulling from
that but don't worry because they're
shooting all year actors will be coming
and going they're filming all these
other movies at the same time too
they're filming Black Panther right now
obviously Black Panther is going to be
an infinity war so he'll be bouncing
back and forth between sets just like
the other actors they're starting
ant-man in the wasp really soon those
actors are going to be an infinity war
so imagine infinity war the movie is
like this giant base camp of Marvel
their giant headquarters with all these
other satellite movies filming with
people going back and forth throughout
the rest of the year the really
important story details they revealed is
that Tony Stark is the person who is
leading the charge he's more mature at
least they call him more mature in this
movie whatever that means he keeps
seeing that vision that Scarlet Witch
gave him the hour he keeps
hallucinating stuff like that he knows
that something is coming in the way that
Thor had visions during Avengers age of
Ultron of the infinity gem so that's why
Kevin Feige said that it was really
important that they break the Avengers
apart and do civil war so that they were
completely unprepared for Thanos so
Robert Downey jr. even teased the
Captain America is still kind of on his
list even though he doesn't
absolutely hate him they're not really
speaking that much so even though they
had that day one moment in the set on
this teaser it looks like they're in
outer space it looks like it picks up
with the guardians of the galaxy that
doesn't necessarily mean that is where
the movie is going to begin that's just
one of the first things they started
filming but it does look an awful lot
like sanctuary and really cool they said
that Thanos is supposed to be the main
character of Infinity Ward the way you
follow him around the way the story is
centered on him like you would see Iron
Man be the main character of an Iron Man
film so it's almost like Panos is
getting his own solo movie with a bunch
of Avengers get starring in it but
that's kind of what the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline is in the comics the
Avengers just come in and out the other
heroes the Infinity watch Adam warlock
and I know everybody's asking about Adam
warlock he was nowhere to be found in
any of this concept art it doesn't seem
like the movies are doing him but if we
see anything different I'll totally do a
video about it but I'm assuming for now
he is not going to be a part of the
NCU but they do have a Yesha who's sort
of like an Adam warlock clone in the
guardians of the galaxy sequel so I had
a link to that video at the end of this
I talked a little bit about her she
seems like the closest at a warlock that
we're going to get she's grown into
cocoon just like him that's why she has
cold skin so other big character reveals
though there's some concept art you see
a new design for Thanos without his
armor on you see Thor with rocket racoon
going to town looking like he has a
different version of the hammer this was
one of the biggest things that you guys
were going crazy about on Twitter last
night everyone was going nuts like what
is he holding this does not look like
Mjolnir so what I think is going on is
that it's either his war axe that he has
in the comics right now which I'm not
going to try and print out or more
likely what I think it is is this
ultimate Thor's axe hammer which is
Mjolnir but just from a different
universe so that brings up a whole bunch
of questions that's a potential spoiler
for Thor Ragnarok so there's only a
couple ways that he could actually get a
more hardcore version of Mjolnir one
would be the multiverse explainer which
is where Doctor Strange would come in
because he has gone into different
dimensions or two slightly more likely
they just reforged mule near in the
course of whatever big final battle they
have at the end of Thor Ragnarok and he
gets a more hardcore version of the
hammer with the ax on it but it's
basically just ultimate Thor's hammer
from The Ultimates universe and they
actually just did that in the comics now
if you've been reading the Thor comics
Jane Foster's been wielding the main
universes version of Mjolnir in unworthy
Thor like our version of Thor is getting
ready to get ultimate Thor's hammer so
in the movies just because they tend to
simplify things I think it's just more
likely that something happens to Mjolnir
and they have to reforge it and it
becomes a much more hardcore version of
that so you guys can let me know what do
you think that he's wielding in this but
it looks like they purposefully kept
this off the page just so they wouldn't
openly reveal it but you can see the
curve here like the hammer has no curve
so this is definitely a different weapon
speaking of new toys
what about iron man's armory this is in
the New Avengers facility so you see he
does have an armory in there hopefully
we'll see it during spider-man
homecoming or at least get a teaser for
it but he's going to be getting all
kinds of new suits during the movie
because it's a space-based movie I think
most of us agree that it'll probably be
a bit
area of the model 45 version of the suit
that he wore when he was traveling with
the guardians of the galaxy it was just
a version that was designed to function
in deep space in a way that his normal
armor was not sort of as a tangent to
that
Spider Man suit because he's the kid on
the team Tony isn't super jazzed up
about throwing him into harm's way it's
possible that he'll get some minor tech
upgrades but I'm not expecting
full-blown comic-book iron spider but
the Russos did tease a long time ago
like way back last year that he would
have a new version of the suit they just
didn't say how different that suit would
be but he's effectively wearing an iron
spider suit to begin with because it was
designed by Tony Stark the reason they
call it the iron spider suit in the
comics is just because it's designed by
Tony Stark but it's literally made of
the same metals that Iron Man suits are
made of so maybe in the way that Iron
Man suit will be designed to function in
deep space
maybe Spider Man will get a slightly
beefed up version but I still think you
know because of whatever their sharing
arrangement is with Sony it will still
look very much like the Spider Man
colors they're not going to do a
completely different color scheme
probably a better example would be the
evolution of the Captain America suit it
gets a little bit cooler a little more
tactical as you go along so I'm
expecting the same thing with Spider Man
suit but it'll still look like comic
book Spider Man what about the infinity
gems though so if the intro from the
collector didn't tip the hat enough the
collector will be in the movie he's one
of the elders of the universe so
obviously he's going to be a really
important figure he still has the
reality gem from the end of Thor the
dark world so either he's going to have
to parlay with Panos or something's
going to happen because that gem is
going to make it into that gauntlet
eventually meanwhile over in Thor
Ragnarok Jeff Goldblum is playing
another elder of the universe the Grand
Master so he'll probably have something
to do with daños and the infinity gems
as well vision still has the mind gem in
his forehead so something crazy is going
to have to happen to him the soul gem is
really the last one that we're waiting
for so we have black panther in store
Ragnarok for that to show up there's a
number of different ways you could
justify that showing up in those movies
so even if the soul gem doesn't appear
during Thor Ragnarok will at least get
confirmation of when it will show up but
just a reminder that both of these
Avengers films will film back-to-back so
just expect a whole bunch of
this behind-the-scenes stuff to be
happening throughout the year as actors
come and go from the set like calm
Holland for instance has to go start
working on the Spider Man sequel
eventually so he'll be doing infinity
war stuff he'll be doing press tour
stuff for the first spider-man
homecoming film and then like way later
this year they'll start pre-production
for the next spider-man film because
they've already confirmed that second
spider-man film I think nobody is
doubting that it's going to make
billions of dollars of course they're
going to be making more Tom Holland
spider-man movies so what I'll probably
do on Monday is a fan OHS comic book
storyline video just to explain some of
the differences between the comic and
what the movie might be cutting out of
that because it is such a big story
there are so many times and so many
characters but there's going to be a
whole bunch more Avengers bunch more
Spider Man Thor Ragnarok coming soon
there will be some sore back nirach next
week too because there's some special
Thor bonus features on the Doctor
Strange blu-ray so I'll do videos for
that stuff next week what's going to
happen next is I'll post my Lego Batman
Easter Egg video tonight just to give
you guys a chance to see the movie is a
crazy number of Easter eggs it was
actually a really funny movie but
congratulations to the new Spider Man
giveaway winner Jon Hurtado you have
quite a profile image there so please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you in one of those Spider Man
Hasbro figures there's a new round it
started in this video I'll just announce
the winner the next time I post a Marvel
video so maybe some store Ragnarok on
Sunday it's been awhile since I've done
the Thor video where you wait for that
you can click here to re-watch that
infinity war teaser a billion times and
you can click here to check all the
videos you may have missed this week
thank you so much for watching everyone
let's high five I'll see you in the next
video